[Music]
andre is in indiana can online only
banks be trusted sure
some of them have better interest rates
on savings and checking accounts which
is appealing sure
i'm old school it scares me to use a
bank with no physical branches how does
it work and is it safe well if they're
an fdic bank it's safe
i don't worry about it um fdic bank and
um
you know most people these days do
the vast majority of their banking
online anyway
um
and so the number of times that you do a
physical deposit or a physical
withdrawal at the actual bank is fairly
low in this world today
so it's not unusual at all to do that
it might be that it's not your only bank
um
some people are more comfortable with
that than others and since you're not
that comfortable with it right now andre
it'd be a way for you to dip your toe in
the water to move some of your
transactions there or some portion of
your banking there
and just get comfortable with the
process and how that particular bank
transacts
and um but yeah there's some there's
some better interest rates for things
like um uh you know your emergency funds
and those kinds of things in those
situations allies got i think 2.2 right
now as an online and um a friend of mine
this week was telling me that he just
said okay allies got 2.2 he walked into
his bank and said you want me to move it
to ally or you want to give me 2.2 and
then they matched it at his bank just
you know they're trying to keep the
deposits in place um because his
particular bank was 1.9 he said so um
not that that point three is going to
change your life it's really not but
um
you get some competitive things like
that with online that you might that
some of the brick and mortar or click
and mortar even don't have so you could
try it it's not a big deal
i am not worried about it i would do
want to see fdic
on it and i do want to see
something that i have some sense of
recognition that this is a
trustworthy organization there's got to
be some reason that i'm willing to put
my money there
so good question